thus in contrast to specific laws we
have universal attraction or the pure
notion of law insofar as pure notion has
looked on as the essence or the true
inner being the determinate Ness of the
specific law it's all still belongs to
appearance or rather to sensuous being
but the pure notion of law transcends
not merely the law which being itself a
specific law stands contrasted with
other specific laws but also transcends
law as such the determinate nests of
which we spoke is itself really only a
vanishing moment which can no longer
occur here as something essential for
here it is only the law that is the true
but the notion of law is turned against
law itself that is to stay in law the
difference itself is grasped immediately
and taken up into the universal thereby
however giving the moments whose
relation is expressed by the law a
subsistence in the form of indifferent
and merely implicit essentiality z-- but
these parts of the difference present in
the law are at the same time themselves
determinate science the pure notion of
law as universal attraction must to get
its true meaning be grasped in such a
way that in it as what is absolutely
simple or unitary the differences
present in law as such themselves return
again into the inner world as a simple
unity this unity is the inner necessity
of the law
in the previous sections where Hagel has
introduced this notion of law which held
out the promise of being able to carry
out the kind of unification that we
didn't see force as able to do a
unification for the understanding
subject what we see me happen is a
number of laws were able to be brought
under the heading of one one and here in
151 Hegel is going to explore that
dynamic so what we've got going on is a
number of different levels you might say
all at the same time and there's
consciousness which is able to cognize
these and chart out their relationship
to each other he's going to say that the
pure notion of law goes against law in a
certain way and so that's going to be
the the crux of this how does that come
to pass well let's think about what the
laws actually do before we go into the
text itself you notice I've got these
specific laws here and there could be a
multiplicity of them there could be 38
specific laws that are all brought under
the heading of one particular law on
that that usually seems like scientific
progress to us right if we're able to
come up with a unified account whether
it be in physical terms or sociological
terms it seems like we're making some
some progress by moving towards higher
and higher levels of abstraction that
attraction but abstraction and getting
to the essence of things now the
particular the specific laws apply to
particular phenomena and they have that
same structure that force had earlier
where there's a realm of things that are
that are different from each other
and force as it moves out into its
expression out of it out of its you know
interior already into its being an
appearance for us it's its exterior
already it extends at to and unifies all
these particulars and we saw in the
previous discussions that what this does
is introduce a flux of difference so the
law is supposed
to be something fix something in
certainly static something even eternal
in the change in the difference in the
flocks of the particular appearances the
particular things that we're seeing and
Hegel says that were able to see them as
appearance precisely because of their
lawfulness because they have this this
being bound together in that way and
then we can go from you know specific
laws here in the case of universal
attraction he talks about you know the
laws of celestial bodies you know the
planets the Suns
you know the stars all the other
phenomena the laws that apply to falling
bodies here in our own observable
existence whether it be that of
ballistics or that of other things and
those can all be brought under the
heading of one main process one main
intelligible structure universal
attraction so that holds a lot of
promise for us doesn't it he's using
this for a example for a reason he says
in contrast to specific laws we have
universal attraction or he says the pure
notion of law but it's not really the
pure notion of law because universal
attraction itself is one law among other
laws all right so we not only have
multiplicity down here at the level of
the particulars we not only have
multiplicity down here at the level of
specific laws we actually so long as
we're dealing with something that has
determinate Ness we're going to have
multiple laws in place so that none of
them are really the pure notion of law
so he says insofar as this pure notion
has looked at is the essence or the true
inner being the determinate of the
specific law still belongs to appearance
so where we thought that we were sort of
coming enough appearance here at this
level it turns out that all of this is
really within the realm of appearance so
physical laws you know laws of
psychology laws in what ever since we
want to talk about so long as they apply
to determinate features of experience to
determinate processes to determinate
ranges of being they are not the pure
notion of law itself so how are we able
then to grasp this pure notion of law
itself and contrast essence against
appearance that's a very important
question the answer to that of course is
well it's really consciousness that's
doing it it's not law by itself doing it
consciousness is making a contribution
so he says the determinate of which we
spoke is itself really only a vanishing
moment which can no longer occur here
something essential for here it is only
the law that is the truth what he means
there is the pure notion of law again we
see this language of vanishing moments
what we thought we could take for
granted as our stopping point for
foreign consciousness in its process of
examining itself and how it engages with
everything else consciousness has
revealed to us that this is not actually
such a stable stopping point that just
like everything else this is going to
when we start pulling on the threads
unravel so he says the pure notion of
law transcends not merely the law which
being itself a specific law stands
contrasted with other specific laws but
also transcends law as such that's a
little mind-boggling isn't it the notion
of something transcends that thing as
such but this is part of the dialectical
process there is a self transcendence
going on at an activity in which law
itself is revealing itself through its
notion a notion for the understanding
right as being more
than what we originally took it as so
this is actually a process of gaining
something not just a process of losing
not just a process of vanishing he says
the notion of laws turned against law
itself that is to say in the law the
difference itself is grasped immediately
and taken up into the universal so what
does that mean that's pretty strange
jargon there remember what happens with
laws right the difference is at the
level of the multiple if those are taken
up into a universal that can happen not
only in terms of law and phenomena but
also in terms of laws and a greater law
and then it can happen in terms of more
universal laws and law itself they're
taken up into this universal giving the
moments whose relation is expressed by
the law right the moments are supposed
to be connected with each other in
certain ways the law is supposed to be
structuring that expressing it that's
why we wanted laws in the first place
because it was providing us with a
certain intelligibility says it gives
them a subsistence in the form of
indifferent and merely implicit
essentiality so indifferent and merely
implicit essentiality x' when we're
looking at the the world and we're
looking at things and we're trying to
make sense of them through this notion
through this activity you might even say
law we are trying to hold on to their
determinate nosov out things is not so
that we can turn them all like you know
via some great metaphysical blender into
the same dull gray soup it's so that we
can preserve what we actually have also
understand the essential structure of
what we have we want the essence but we
also want the appearance so the problem
here is that the very working of law has
a ten
see to flatten everything out to turn
differences into those that are merely
indifferent those that don't matter
those that don't really make a
difference as we've said before so he
says these these parts of the difference
present in the water at the same time
determinate signs so the pure notion of
law is universal attraction must to get
to its true meaning be grasped in such a
way that in it what is absolutely simple
or unitary what is absolutely simple or
unitary in this here Hegel is gonna say
something kind of tricky isn't me the
differences present in law as such
themselves return again to into the
inner world as a simple unity so what is
unity unity is actually the whole set of
differences he's talking about totality
as well as unity here and all of that
has to be sort of taken up into this
notion of law he says so this in this
unity is the inner and here he
introduces a key term necessity of the
law why talk about necessity again I
want to remind us that when we're
talking about the meaning of law what
we're talking about is something that
the mind can grasp that brings
intelligibility to this wide range of
phenomena ultimately if it's supposed to
be the law governing everything if it's
the unconditioned Universal we've been
seeking it actually has to bring
intelligibility to everything now how is
that possible what do we require in
order to have intelligibility you know
in a lot of cases we can have things
that are contingent be intelligible so
I'm going to you know walk around now or
either flip my tie why am i doing that's
a contingent action we could actually
explain it in terms of well doctors say
they wanted to demonstrate what a
contingent action was so he flipped his
tie
and the tie happened to be in the right
place at the right time you notice
what's happening all these different
sort of causal relations and factors are
coming together in a way that allows
this action to happen right it's silly
action right almost something out of
Laurel and Hardy of the Three Stooges
but what is this illustrate to us why
was I doing that I wanted to illustrate
something about intelligibility somehow
there's a connection between these hey
you would call that necessity there are
different ranges different you might say
amounts or degrees of necessity for
Hegel necessity and intelligibility
interfused with each other so when
something is arbitrary Ville Kerr in you
know German
you know dependent on the will or just
dependent on something happen you know
by chance we really don't understand it
this is an idea that goes all the way
back to antiquity when Aristotle was
talking about seeking out the causes of
things he's talking about trying to find
some manner of necessity and that has to
do with grasping the essence of things
not merely the appearance its grasping
the essence that runs through those
appearances when Cicero you know rejects
the views of the the Epicureans in the
in the de fato
saying look you know whenever we
actually have something intelligible
there has to be some cause for it he is
a Hegel would say dimly seeking the same
sort of thing that Hegel is more
explicitly and articulating not more
explicitly and articulately setting out
for us so we want necessity and Hegel
thinks that we're really only going to
get this through the pure notion of law
not through these other laws which are
easier for us to handle
the law is there by present in a
two-fold manner once as law in which the
differences are expressed as independent
moments and also in the form of a simple
withdrawal into itself which again can
be called force but in the sense not of
a force that is driven back into itself
but force as such or the notion of force
an abstraction which absorbs the
differences themselves of what attracts
and what is attracted in this sense
simple electricity for example is force
but the expression of difference falls
within the law this difference is
positive and negative electricity in the
case of the motion of falling force is
the simple factor gravity whose law is
that the magnitudes of the different
moments of the motion the time elapsed
in the space traversed are related to
one another as root and square
electricity itself is not different per
se or is not in its essence the dual
essence of positive and negative
electricity hence it is usually said
that it has the law of this mode of
being and to that it has the property of
expressing itself in this way it is true
that this property is the essential and
sole property of this force or that it
belongs to it necessarily but necessity
here is an empty word force must just
because it must duplicate itself in this
way of course given a positive
electricity negative to is given in
principle for the positive in ISM only
as related to a negative or the positive
is in its own self the difference from
itself and similarly with the negative
but that electricity as such should
divide itself in this way is not in
itself a necessity electricity a simple
force is indifferent to its law to be
positive and negative and if we call the
former its notion but the latter it's
being then its notion is indifferent to
its being it merely has this property
which just means that this property is
not in itself necessary to it this
indifference is given another form when
it is set that to be positive and
negative belongs to the definition of
electricity and that this is simply its
notion and essence in that case it's
being would simply mean its
actual existence but that definition
does not contain the necessity of its
existence it exists either because we
find it that is its existence is not
necessary at all or else it exists
through or by means of other forces that
is its necessity is an external
necessity but in basing this necessity
on the determinant of being through
another we relapse again into the
plurality of specific laws which we have
just left behind in order to consider
law as law it is only with law as law
that we are to compare its notion as
notion or its necessity but in all these
forms necessity has shown itself to be
only an empty word
and section 152 Hegel is going to be
exploring along with us this
understanding of the relationship
between necessity and law and it's very
easy to automatically assume that well
if there's a law or something that
provides us with total necessity that's
what it means to have a law but if we
start exploring the way that laws are
conceptualized and how they apply to the
ranges of things that within the realm
of appearance they do we find that
although there is often the appearance
of necessity at least at this point
we're not arriving at something that we
can say is in fact a robust necessity so
Hegel is going to tell us that law
itself splits into two sides he says its
present in a two-fold manner he says its
present as Aloha in which the
differences are expressed as independent
moments and also in the form of a simple
withdrawal into itself which again can
be called force and he wants to specify
here because he was reintroducing this
notion of force not force he says that
is driven back into itself of force as
such the notion of force and what is
that that's an abstraction that absorbs
differences so when we have a law we
already have this conception of force at
work it really is a conception it's an
abstraction the law gives us these
differences to which the law is some
somehow supposed to get its hooks it's
supposed to extend into these it's
supposed to cover them all it's supposed
to bind them all into a sort of a
conceptual unity for us in which the
differences become really indifferent
and then the force as such is supposed
to somehow take these differences and
absorb them so you can think of this as
the the working of law this is what is
required for law to actually function
it gets a little bit easier to wrap our
heads around this when we look at the
examples that he's providing and if we
don't look at the examples that he's
providing we won't actually get through
the insights that are coming out of them
so he says in this sense simple
electricity for example is force right
it is a abstraction that absorbs
differences when we use the word
electricity we have some sort of
conception we're not thinking
necessarily in terms of positive and
negative although that's going to turn
out to be really really important when
we're actually trying to do anything in
the world with electricity or to explain
things like why did the lightning hit
over there we have to think in terms of
positive and negative and that falls
under the law the explanation the
regularity that's going on then we say
that the force expresses itself in this
way in terms of positive and negative
with electricity you don't get you know
five different flavors or something like
that and they they are in relation to
each other as positive and negative not
just as blue and red or you know other
kinds of opposites they are opposed to
each other through polarity right so she
says the expression of difference falls
within the law this difference is
positive and negative electricity or we
would probably say in a positive and
negative charge and you can include
other things in there how are the
positive and the negative related to
each other we can get much more you know
specific about this but hingle doesn't
want to get into all those sort of
details at this point so he says in the
case of the motion of falling right
we're thinking about say projectiles or
dropping a piece of chalk or planets you
know whatever satellite orbiting a
planet we have a force and we call that
force gravity now does gravity express
itself in the same form see what's going
on here is we not only have different
content positive and negative
we have a different form the positive is
related to the negative in a different
way than time is related to space or to
magnitude you could really say all three
of these are fitting in together I know
that for Hegel
time and space are already connected
with magnitude just put them aside for a
moment the reason why I put three years
I wanted to really stress that we're
dealing with a different form here not
just different content I mean positive
and negative are definitely different
content than time or magnitude or space
but these things are related to each
other in very different ways we have a
difference of content and we have a
fundamental difference of form between
the ways in which these two laws
governing things are expressing
themselves what does that mean
well there are some implications for
that so let's follow the map he says
forces the simple factor gravity you
know the magnitudes etc it said right
electricity itself is not difference per
se or is not in its essence the dual
essence of positive and negative
electricity that's this is the essence
of it right hence it's usually something
that has the law of this mode of being
and it has the property of expressing
itself this way so we have a phenomenon
it has to express itself in a
determinate way since it is true that
this property is the essential and sole
property of this force or that it
belongs to it necessarily so we think
that we have some sort of necessity
right if you've got electricity then you
have to have positive and negative
that's that's the rules of the game if
you're dealing with electricity you can
try to make up other rules but now
you're not dealing with electricity
you've got some other thing in mind
right
likewise motion of falling there's a
certain necessity here and we can even
say there's a certain intelligibility
that is Co relative to that necessity
right we can conceptualize it and we can
plan
and we can explain it to somebody else
and feel like we know what we're talking
about precisely because these things are
connected with each other has the
property right so he says it's true that
this is this is belonging to it
necessarily but necessity here is an
empty word what does he mean by that
well there is necessity and then you
might say there's necessity with a
capital end real necessity necessity
that conditions necessity I should have
probably not done the capital I'm here
but too late for that right
what would provide us with that let's
follow this out a little bit more he
says of course given positive
electricity negative is given to in
principle for the positive is only as
related to a negative right but that
electricity as such should divine itself
in this way is not in itself a necessity
what could make it a necessity oh you
would need something else structuring
electricity and saying you got to do
things this way Amanda you know we're
dealing with a level of bosses
electricity bosses around the phenomenon
says here's the way I want things done
forms need to be filled out and positive
and negative right that's the way
activities work but you know there's a
bigger boss and you can say well the
bigger boss is the one who said that
this actually has to go this way how do
you get in that office and find the
bigger boss that's the question so he
says it just has this property right the
notion of electricity is indifferent to
its being it merely has this property
which means that this property is not in
itself necessary to it this indifference
is given another form when it is said to
be positive and negative blocks the
definition of electricity and that this
is simply its notion in essence but he
says in that case it's being when simply
means actual existence but that's not
we're trying to get at just the the
sheer fact isset e of it we want to
understand it right we want to make
sense of it so he says that definition
does not contain the necessity of its
existence it exists either because we
find it and if we just happen to run
across it that's not necessary
that's not contributing necessity to us
or it exists through and by means of
other forces all right and we can say
the same thing by the way about gravity
why does it have to show itself in this
way why does it have to structure things
along these lines well there has to be
something else governing this and that
would provide us with real necessity
wouldn't it but we don't have that you
don't we'd encounter electricity we
encounter gravity we conceptualize them
and we have we've gotten behind those
two the force governing all of those not
yet we certainly haven't or have we he
says in basing this necessity on the
determinate nosov being through another
we relapse again into the plurality of
specific laws which we've just left
behind in order to consider law as law
all right so we're placed back after
doing a bit of investigation in a
similar starting point now whenever he
GLE does that you notice that it's never
quite exactly the same starting point
things don't just repeat themselves over
and over again in a cycle is more like a
spiral where we get closer and closer
and closer to the center but we've now
realized that these specific laws where
we thought we had some necessity going
on
because the very structure of law we
don't actually have a necessity the
truth the essence of law is not yet
available to us he says in all these
forms necessity has shown itself to be
only an empty word does that mean that
we don't have any necessity to look for
that necessity doesn't mean anything no
because the process of study is not yet
finished but it means that we don't have
it at this point and we don't have it
where other people are saying that it is
because they stopped at that point Hegel
wants to go on farther